so
there is a group called mgtow which is
men going their own way which is really
in my estimation kind of like a reaction
to a lot of the feminist propaganda
that's going on uh
today and uh has been going on since the
60s i would say
right with second wave feminism and so
on so there is a
a youtube video that we kind of stumbled
across with
uh conveniently enough an introduction
to mgtow so it's telling us what this
mgtow is
and what we wanted to do as sunni muslim
men is kind of look at this video
and react to it exactly so we're gonna
see the extreme
side opposite the fitbit feminism
hi everyone sandman here i'm getting a
number of people asking me to do an
introduction video for mgtow
so here it is i'm going to cover 25 of
the most important video topics that
i've covered
since i've started my channel and the
first thing to remember about mgtow
is that a man that has taken the
metaphorical red pill is a man that has
learned the ugly truth about female
nature
women are made out to be harmless
beautiful creatures but the truth is
many women today will rip out your heart
and testicles through your wallet and
move on to their next victim
with absolutely no second thoughts so
what do you think of this ali first of
all we'll kind of get a flavor of
it's it's you know he's side of god when
you're saying you know women are seen as
harmless beautiful now
yeah you know some can be seen as
harmless most of them you know yeah
maybe beautiful depends on the one
that's looking maybe it's loaded again
they say beauty is in the eye of the
beginning
i was going to say that but i don't know
how to rephrase it but we've got you
here
so now then it goes a bit um south you
know and he starts going into about
you know what did he say he said like
you know they want to rip you from a
different part of your body yeah take
your wallet
financially so i can see a bit of
extremism in there
i can see me a bit of like okay all
right are they really as
as you say it's hasty generalization it
does seem like that it doesn't matter
and to be honest this is like the men's
right movement
a lot of it has been very balanced a lot
of it like for example warren farrell
he's written
many books which i would recommend like
not to say that i agree with everything
in those books but if you've been
challenged with second word feminism
books like the myth of male power books
like
the liberated man books like recently
he's written a book called the boy
crisis
books like this would actually give you
another perspective honestly on
i'm not saying once again i agree with
everything but it will give you another
perspective and also watching that
documentary the red pill the red pill
yeah it's a fantastic it will give you
another perspective
okay because critically what warren
farrell does is he redefines power what
power what power is
and power is the ability he says for a
man to take control of his own life or a
woman
right and he says that basically his
main argument thrust of
his main argument but obviously you need
to see his evidencing in his books
is that if if power is defined as the
ability for a man or woman to take power
of their own life
there's many things that men do which
show powerlessness for example
being forced to go into the army going
forced to
to financially provide being for or
expected at least to do so
you know and many other examples that he
gives like dangerous jobs many examples
that he gives
and he also references you know the
increase of suicide for men etc
and it's more of a sober tone and i
think really this conversation
is that opinions are great they're very
good but in order for us to really make
good cases
on either side whether you're talking
about women's rights or women's rights
it needs to be academically referenced
otherwise it will not be respected
and i think that's an important thing so
let's see if you would take a notch down
or
not up ultra remorse in the process so
taking the red pill is making yourself
aware of how
women operate and you stop being naive
about it
with regards to becoming a mgtow there
are four or five different levels to
mgtow the first level is the purple pill
man
this is the man that's aware that women
use the government the courts
and men's desires to reproduce to take
advantage of men
but the purple pill man believes that
the risks of a relationship in marriage
are often worth the potential punishment
a level 2 mgtow believes in dating
and short-term relationships but not
marriage long-term relationships or
cohabitation with women
to him these often seem very dangerous a
level 3 mgtow doesn't believe in dating
women at all
and limits his interactions with women
as much as possible
a level four mgtow tries to limit his
interaction yeah
what do you think of this bro i don't
know he's broken it down to level so
to me it does seem like look he might
have some valid points but to me is
this is as good as listening to a
super extreme radical feminist who's
been abused by a man so much that she's
decided to become a lesbian
yeah to that level where she just got so
much hate it's just another part of the
spectrum another angle where as if i
feel as if
this man has been really hurt um
being used mistreated um and his emotion
and how his feeling could be correct
but to generalize that again because
that was gonna take a bit notch down but
he's actually
now breaking the levels down but he's
even he's even giving you advice like
what you should do
yes but his prescription doesn't seem to
be yeah i mean
he doesn't obviously this is an
introduction video maybe he's done some
other place
but his description of limiting his
interaction with women as much as
possible for me
i don't see what does that mean why is
he saying he doesn't want any kind of
intimacy or is he
what's he talking about quite frankly it
seems like a cowardly approach
like sorry to say if if you think this
is being an alpha male
and this is the kind of language they
use alpha and beta male 1 but being an
alpha male
or being a real man or if you want to
call it that whatever you want to say
is not trying to avoid women right away
from the state or from the government as
he goes on to say
it's not this it's actually facing all
those things and face
no seriously facing them and cooperating
with them as much as possible
and there are times where conflict is
required and sometimes when negotiation
is required
and the real man knows and real woman
knows when to do either of those things
exactly he's more easily manipulated a
man aware of how women
function in society and manipulate men
in covert ways
are harder to guilt and shame into doing
the things that she wants
he knows the game so he's harder to
trick into marriage
protection and resource extraction shame
is the name of many women's game
and in this case it doesn't work after a
woman convinces her beta male blue pill
man that marriage is a good idea for him
then she has a child or two which at
some point allow her to leave that
relationship
and use those children as a way to get
child support from her husband
people wonder why men go their own way
and one of the biggest reasons is that
they have been burned by women through
the divorce courts
and are often paying lifetime alimony as
well as child support to their ex-wives
in many cases the family courts also
award the full value of the family home
to wives
and the majority of men visiting this
youtube channel are often in their 30s
40s and 50s men that have been taken to
the cleaners so to speak
and have had their eyes opened a little
too late
so interesting look okay this
interesting point and there's truth to
that yeah
so even though if it's coming from a
radical feminist or
minimalist or whatever you wanna call it
yeah it's
it's a reality a lot of men are really
really trying their best to abstain from
getting married
yeah firstly they're doing everything
that you're doing in marriage anyways
yeah that's point number one but number
two there's too many risks
yeah okay um and they're getting married
and then when things go
sour you have risks of seeing your kids
the state
just takes the woman's side um and
there's a lot of other factors so
can you blame men to not want to get
married no i'm saying he's speaking the
truth there
that men are afraid yes women are using
their powers that are given to them by
authorities
and other means to abuse men so much so
that some men are suicidal
some men that kill themselves because
they do not um they're not
they don't they don't even see that and
the documentary red pill actually
outlines that stuff really well in terms
of i think you have to pay if you want
to watch it but yeah
it's worth the money 100 yeah 100 yeah
definitely yeah
yeah so i i definitely agree uh that's
that's
there are things there which are real
concerns yes exactly they are here to
become mgtows because they are shocked
at the way women took advantage of them
as well they're here to understand how
women use their beauty and behavior to
trick men
another important thing to remember is
that women age like milk
while men age like wine and i'm putting
a link to a video called
women in the wall down below many
women's looks and ability to attract a
wealthy attractive mate decline rapidly
as they hit the age of 30.
men's attractiveness often increases
with age because they tend to make more
money as they age and often
that's that's a fact yeah the fact that
women
no no no let me know that's the fact
when a woman reaches the age of 30
30 alarm bills do go off for a man
that's for a man that's not the case
even reproducing for example a man
probably has a source of seven to
eight-year-old men that are producing
like his happy days brother
so here's a fact and have larger bank
accounts and savings
while generally women's earnings
potential withers with their looks
especially if they've had children
the age of 30 is roughly where male and
female values intersect
and then go in the opposite direction if
a man doesn't get married by the age of
35 or 40
then there's only roughly a 12 percent
chance that he's going to get married
from that point forward
another reason men should go their own
way is because of [__] tests
women often test men's ability to be
providers and tolerate their horrible
behavior
the idea is to turn a man into an
obedient broken shell of his former self
that walks around saying yes dear all of
the time
his spirit has to be broken in many
cases so his resources become more
easily extracted and he is more
malleable he becomes silly putty in her
hands
a woman asking a man to do something
over the top is not her being loving or
showing love
but instead she's testing him to see if
he can be manipulated
and the ironic thing is that women want
to manipulate men
but when the manipulation works they
tend to lose interest
with regards to love there are often
questions as to whether
so about this point he keeps talking
about resource extraction right
and once again i think he's operating i
think it's ironic right because he's
operating on a feminist paradigm
i'll tell you why i say that because the
question of okay should there be
it's a question of is it complementarity
or legality
is it in a complementarian system or an
egalitarian system
if you believe it should be an
egalitarian system then
financially right both man and woman
husband and wife should be splitting the
bills
okay can you just define the definition
right so when i say
i'm talking about complete equality so
there's there's no
differentiating factor okay i mean ngozi
for example famous feminists uh recently
wrote the feminist manifesto she says
everything should be equal absolutely
equal
except for breastfeeding for example
right for women that's something which
she
she except what does exception stop
there right right that's the point so we
don't accept the premise
we don't accept the premise that
different things should be treated the
same in all aspects
okay and because we don't accept the
premise we say that there are things
that men have to do
responsibilities duties and
responsibilities which women don't
which is called what was that so so for
example in this case he keeps referring
to
as resource extraction okay we don't
accept the premise
that it's resource extraction and
manipulation
we say that having a reciprocal
relationship with a woman
where she will if it's a familial
structure she will have to undergo
a series of difficulties especially
if we consider that she goes through
pregnancy and birth and breastfeeding
that it's not seen from the islamic
paradigm as
as exploitative or manipulative if if we
then reimburse women for these things
exactly and allah says in the quran very
clearly like for example if you divorce
your wife and she's given birth
there are certain legislation allah put
in place yeah he has to
he has to provide money for
breastfeeding because it's a service yes
at the end of the night
if even if she's like divorced she has
to stay at the house until that period
if i'm saying in the quran allah says
yeah for three months for three months
yeah so so so it's
again it is what he was talking about
before is the other extreme which
is the western extreme because the
western extreme says
even in the uk this might be the case
but certainly the u.s is more the case
that if a man marries a woman and he's
got x amount of money in the bank
account and they get a divorce she's
going to get a huge cut
yeah of how much she makes or whatever
that is
and they justify that on the grounds
that she was servicing him like okay
fair enough there should be some kind of
compensation but the amount here
it's as if she was doing the work that
he was doing is completely unjustifiable
do you see how is it one extreme yeah
yeah yeah another female but the point
but the point is
we don't refer to this stuff as resource
extraction or manipulation where
men should be proud to spend money on
their families yes
and actually islam defines manhood in a
sense
as a as a man's ability okay to
to to protect to maintain and to spend
on his entire family
provide and that's what the quran says
that men are the maintainers and
protectors of women because of what
allah has given
men that he hasn't given women and
because of what they spend on them isn't
that isn't that isn't that beautiful man
like can you think about
this whole thing of experiment i just
see this for feminism and this what this
guy's on
as some kind of an experiment that
they've gone through and allah has given
us the solution in the quran
and they just they've just gone round in
circles this whole reaction is action
reaction and they've come back to the
hustle which is what allah is mentioned
in the quran right it's all action
reaction like you said bro
action second word feminism oh we feel
exploited because we're
working in the home and we want to do
work you come outside bro
nowadays james truly i was um just
looking at some of his work
right he's from newcastle university
he's done work he's written a book with
a miseducated woman or something like
this right
and he's also done work on second wave
feminism and its effects
and what he's been able to show is that
30 of women
okay 30 of women are
unhappy because of the career options
that they've had or or that they've
prioritized careers
over and above yes family yes and and so
this the second wave feministic
framework has failed and that's why
only eight percent i think of german
people according to yougov and and even
less
in other uh european countries now
identify with feminism in the first
place
because if they've tasted it's fruits
and they're rotten fruits but on the
other hand it's not going to
just be action reaction we need to bring
some kind of complementarity to into the
equation here
and some reciprocity which we'll talk
about hopefully when we get the chance
children and need to divert those
resources elsewhere
anyways mgtow men want north america and
europe to turn into japan
we want men refusing to provide love and
resources to women on a
civilization-wide scale
until society crumbles women are selfish
yet men are told to man up and take
responsibility
and we don't want to take responsibility
for childlike women that have given up
on their own responsibilities
but continue to demand that we men
provide them entitlements
because they have a golden vagina when a
man tries to live for himself
women call it a mid-life crisis and try
to shame him back into submission
yet when a woman goes through menopause
men are supposed to just tolerate her
hot flashes
as well as mood swings but a man in a
midlife crisis
needs therapy according to women the guy
we make
there is some truth in that i mean at
the end of the day is most feminists
agree
that there are physiological differences
between men and women and most of them
would
accept the fact that there are there are
behavioral changes
when menses happens so if th this brings
us to the point
uh equality is not identicality we don't
believe that we're the same and there
are things that men are going to have to
tolerate from women
that the vice versa isn't isn't the case
exactly and then what happens is this
fits into the whole paradigm of
men committing more suicide because as a
woman you're telling me i'm going
through menopause understand me yes i'm
lashing out on you i'm going in a mad
one every now and then
but i'm going for menopause okay but
when a man is going from midlife crisis
you're told to shut up now when you're
told to shut up as a man
not directly or indirectly um because
one of the reasons why a lot of men
commit suicide is because women tend to
express their self more they can cry
about it they can just let it out
as a man you have to man up don't be
weak you don't cry and now
when you're faced with a woman kind of
expressing her feelings and then
belittling you when you're going through
like a let's say a midlife crisis that
adds on to somebody being prone to
commit suicide
i think that's that is one of the things
i mean most studies when they talk about
men
committing suicide more is because
society shames men
for being able to come out and speak
about their emotions in the same way
that women
are actually more courageous in being
able to do so and exactly and you're
suppressing them further with this
that's true so this is these are some
interesting points buying them a nice
home and furnishing it as well as
spoiling them rotten like princesses
yet many of the women they tend to
rescue are used butts that have been
riding the [__] carousel for most of
their lives
and many women prefer to date bad boys
and jerks instead of good
loving supportive and good-hearted men
many men can't even get dates or
relationships these days because they
seem to be unattractive to women
and women have no interest in dating
them and having sex with them
but it's much harder for unattractive
men than it is for unattractive women
and men that are incapable of getting
dates and getting into relationships
are often called tflers or true force
that's true for an attractive man that's
subjective anyways
and for an attractive woman even an
attractive woman like
you know back in the days with friends
some friends would like they would look
at a girl and they'd be like
okay she's not that pretty there but
you know her body or whatever may be is
so an attractive woman still has some
kind of a
demand should i say but uh as an
attractive man that's not the case um
i was i was going to say something else
yeah yeah it's an interesting point
because i think a lot of people don't
realize the chivalry effect
and a chivalry effect is not just
something that happens in the courtroom
or in the
legal system there is a societal
chivalry effect
yeah the thing is also like for example
when they say for example women want
bad guys good guy in bad guys what's
that mean a lot of people go to extremes
yeah in that context where they think
and a man go to that for example a man
is good he's his first relationship
whatever which you shouldn't have
anyways for the get-go this was haram
yeah
but what happens is that woman uses you
or leaves you for a bad boy yeah
in your head you're being told now you
have to be the bad guy now the bad guy
that's
being registered in your head you know
is somebody that's going to be
uh violent or this that there was a
prophet i was listening to on tick-tock
yeah i disagreed with him i agree with
some points
but he's making it seem as if you have
to be
bad and evil to your wife
right to be that's not correct let me
tell you something here psychologically
let me tell you something if i'm a
pushover yeah if
i don't have a backbone and my friends
forget relationship friends colleagues
works you name it brother sister whoever
maybe
if i'm a pushover anyone this is human
psychology
if you're too good to someone i'm never
going to use the word good if you're
just too
lenient with someone they're bound to
trample on you you've got no seriousness
left do you know what i'm trying to say
it's human psychology it doesn't apply
to women or men it applies across
board now to take that on board and run
with it and make it seem as if
no you have to be the bad guy or you
have to treat your harsh i don't think
this is correct yes
definitely it's not great you can treat
your wife good but and
vice versa there has to be discipline in
all areas
okay if you're a pushover woman yeah or
a push of a man
the same thing will apply to you so i
think it's unfair where a lot of people
use this and make it seem as if you know
i have to become the bad boy alpha male
and real hard and i don't think that's
right as long as you have principles in
place
and discipline like there's cross don't
cross that line
works both and don't forget islam like
for a lot of these mgtow brothers that
are
men that are watching this right now
islam has the answer to your questions
because it's institutionalized or
hierarchization
like for instance we're not afraid to
say that men
as husbands yeah there's a degree of
authority in certain uh
aspects and going into a relationship
muslim women know that
they know that for example if there's a
deadlock and there is a
there's not a decision to be made then
yeah the man is going to make a decision
on that on that
so we are not uh the the islamic
paradigm
the islamic paradigm grants to men
something which will satisfy their
nature
and stop men from being resentful to
women because their nature is
suppressed and this is a great injustice
of the feminist movement
that it's not allowed men to express
themselves in the way that they ought to
or need to or feel that they have to
in order to really express what it is
that is different from them
uh from women which differentiates them
from it so for for us
we do have a hierarchy within the house
we do have a hierarchy there is a man
there is
the kids there's the wife and yeah there
is a chain of command at the end of the
day and the man
is is the man of the house the prophet
salla he said
every shepherd is responsible for their
flock
and a man is responsible for his flock
and his his wife is responsible for
for for the for the family and so on so
there is a clear hierarchy that is known
in the religion by necessity yeah
and this allows a man to to not feel
always undermined because he comes up
with a lot of examples where really what
he's talking about is a manipulated man
what is he talking about a man that
doesn't have a backbone a backbone put
it that way yeah and the thing is look
it's not just a religion
this is like predisposition
it's a matter just as you affirm the
oneness of god
this is something allah has legislated
for mankind the one who's created apple
knows how apple works
if you try to experiment you're going to
come back to square one the factory
settings
which is the usual and if you go and
experiment which these people are
no let's try this let's try that it's
nothing but action reaction bro
it's nothing but chaos and what we
learned from this video is
how important it is for example to have
a divine
legislation telling us how to abide and
live by and if you don't what are you
going to do let me tell you something
let's experiment oh explode it didn't
work i hurt my head
you're going to carry on hurting
yourself and we're seeing society
crumbling the marriage the there's an
outright war on the
uh the family unit and you name it and
that's what you're gonna have
extreme individuals like him can you
imagine men can you
imagine a a naive man man
young boy listening to this he's been
hurt by society
and he's like you know what yeah this
woman you radicalized the guy
can you imagine him getting into a
relationship he's going to see this
woman
as nothing but an object not even
he's going to say this woman is trying
to suck myself it's like what stephen
covey says you know his seven rules for
highly effective people yeah
it's one of his rules is think win win
and i think the key word here is
reciprocity
if you you always think it's a zero-sum
game which in economic terms means it's
either me or you
who's gonna win here and basically the
presentation of this man here is that
this thing is a whole
this gender interaction is a zero-sum
game it's the same and
it's the same discourse exactly as we
find in
a second wave movements or feminist
movements which is that
men are biologically oppressive by
nature the the family is institutionally
oppressive
there's a patriarchy which is basically
this term they say they're not
discriminatory towards men
but there is a whole term with the word
patriarchy where the word patriot
literally means
that which relates to the father the man
right so
you're telling us feminists are
basically saying this
that the name of your movement is named
after being a woman feminism
and then the name of the oppressive
force is named after manhood which is
patriarchy
so you've got this dualism you've got
this you've got this dichotomy that's
created
this dualism where men are the bad guys
and women
are the good guys and this guy is doing
nothing but the opposite women now have
become the
antagonist and men have become the
protagonist and we need to kind of
avenge
yeah like kind of the historical
injustice by secluding ourselves
which is a cowardly approach it is a
cowardly approach and it's an
ineffective approach it's an inefficient
approach
the complementarity model that islam has
to offer once again
like you've just mentioned it does not
say
that men and women are the same it
acknowledges the differences between men
and women
it acknowledges the psychological and
the biological and the physiological
differences
and it makes special arrangements
for those all right so a man doesn't
feel like him expressing himself
is going to compromise a woman
expressing herself and a woman doesn't
have to feel like
her expressing herself is gonna
compromise the man
a traditional marriage and family is a
great risk for men in this day and age
if a man wants a child of his own i
would suggest that he go to either
mexico or thailand
and have a surrogate mother give birth
to his own child
that way his child can never be taken
away by the mother
and he often pays thirty to forty
thousand dollars to have his own child
free do you see the extremes he's gone
through he's literally telling you to
travel to another country
and get a surrogate mother can you
imagine the extremes that
this is this is very worrying you know
what the show this show this guy is
either his kids have been taken away
from him that is always happening he's
going to extremely
bro remember when we went to california
let me tell you something yeah but we
went to california we're not going to
mention what state or what happened but
we went to california and abroad yes
i remember look you don't you just said
it i know man and tell
tell them the story man bro if we're
talking about the the same story
it's when the when the guy his kids were
custody went to the mother and he
couldn't see his kids and then what did
he do
yeah he yeah he shoot him he shot the
two
daughters and he shot himself yes yes he
shot the two daughters
obviously that's a condemnable action a
monstrous action but the point is
it drives men to insanity bro yes
when you play around with kids yes and
this is a serious issue and once again
it's documented very well in the red
pill
um documentation it's extremely and
people do this today man
people are trying to snatch kids away
from the father and this can mentally
disturb them to the point of insanity
it's it's something people don't realize
how big of an injustice this is this is
this is a
massive injustice and you know what this
is you know women have been given power
here and this is one thing that
warren farrell mentions in his book the
myth of male power which is that
he mentioned a beautiful example he says
look if a woman
especially a second word feminist woman
right she goes into a
an institution and she now she's a
manager of like five or ten people and
then they
tell her look you're going to be
supervising 20 people she'll see that as
an expansion of responsibility
but if she has three kids and then she
has two more she won't see that as an
expansion of responsibility
but the same thing has happened in fact
the influence that she will have
on the kids is going to be more than the
influence that she'll have on the
employees
the point is a woman is extremely
influential
okay and yes there is a conditional
there she will be more influential
if she is a mother but yeah the same
could be said about
their understanding which is a distorted
understanding of the patriarchy the man
is sometimes more authoritative and yes
he should be to counterbalance to
counterbalance this
uh this huge influence and authority
that women would have imagine if there
was equality man
imagine if a man had to have the same
authority as a woman and that the woman
was so much more influential over the
kids because she has literally had those
kids in her stomach
and literally had that connection with
them that the man can never no matter
how much he tries
ever have that connection that needs to
be counterbalanced and islam has the
solution which is
that he has an authority over that woman
that she does not have over him you know
you know what
and nothing should end on this note here
you know what's really profound is that
the reason why these authorities give
that right to the woman is because they
accept that she has bore them and given
birth to them
so they say hold on a second the mother
here is the one that's playing the key
role the responsibility and
carried that child and giving birth they
see that and say you know what
they they put that respect on the
motherhood right and that's why they
give that right
um to the mother yeah sometimes to
extremes yes but you get but do you see
how they're coming back to our principle
of the quran
that yes that mother the mother like the
mother how she's with the kids etc she
has that right
uh islamically as well but do you see
how it falls back to our paradigm
that they are not the same beautiful do
you get it
they're implementing in their illegal
system absolutely oh yeah i got one more
thing which is 950.
in her 30s and she will say things like
not tonight honey and deny him sexual
release
and possibly use that as a way to
control him oh bro
how many views are once he's got like
almost a million almost a million views
000 likes 1.4 000 um dislikes
that's about nine percent of dislikes of
the full um count
yeah yeah this is an issue bro one
second is an issue
yes please yeah if i was to repeat the
same thing i'm gonna put my feet up no
oh yeah there's a reason behind it
there's a reason yeah
if i said the same thing and i quoted
the hadith which the process
said that the angels cursed a woman who
when the the the husband is asking for
intimacy she says no so first you can
see from the hadith that
it doesn't say go grab her by the hair
and say come here and i'm going to
wherever you too yeah
because it shows that she has the right
to say no absolutely
this is a fact that this guy is stating
and yes you know what in this hadith it
looks like the man is actually sexually
uh blackmailing it's actually the
opposite way around she's saying no
and i i i don't want you that's
manipulation now we're not saying this
is we're not saying there's certain
scenarios where a woman can't yeah no no
but
what's the point of a relationship
exactly what we're saying is this
talking about a woman that is actually
using her
femininity against the man yes and
nobody talks about it so much so that
when you read the hadith
you're reading it with a a oh this
sounds oh my gosh towards a woman
hold on a second exactly why isn't this
hadith scene i thought in a second
she is actually abusing him so much so
that the angels are cursing her yeah
no you know i think that there's an
assumption here which i think second
we're feminists once again
have tried to promulgate and it's the
assumption that both men and women are
the same sexually
but look at this i'm just gonna i'm just
ladies yeah look open it brother i'm
gonna give you one
you know one second yeah nonsense okay
okay this this is one study that was
from roy
baumiesta i might be pronouncing their
wrong name wrong
and catholic canton cantonese yeah and
another one kathleen v
divos and there and the question is that
doesn't sound like muslims no it's
definitely not
is there a gender difference in strength
of sex drive yeah that's the name of the
question
okay listen to the abstract the sex
drive refers to the
strength of sexual motivation across
many studies
and measures men have been shown to be
to have more frequent and more make sure
the mic is closer right and more intense
sexual desires than women as reflected
spontaneous
in spontaneous thoughts about sex
frequency
frequent frequency and variety of sexual
fantasies
desired frequency of intercourse desired
number of partners masturbation
and i know some people in this room know
a bit about that
i'm only joking lacking for various uh
sexual practices
willingness to forgo sex initiating
versus refusing sex
making sacrifices for sex yeah no
comment
and other measures listen to this listen
to this
and for a psycholo psychological um kind
of peer-reviewed study to write the
following
in such generalized terms is incredible
no contrary findings indicating stronger
sexual motivation among women were found
hence that repeated no contrary findings
including
indicating stronger sexual motivations
among women were found
hence listen hence we conclude that the
male sex drive is stronger than the
female sex drive
the gender difference in sex drive
should not be generalized to other
constructs such as sexual orgasmic
or orgasmic capacity enjoyment of sex or
extrinsically motivated something you've
never experienced in your life
look here's the point let me tell you
something right the assumption once
again of identicality
falls flat on its face like this mic
right any
serious scientist or psychologist or
social scientists
will know that all studies really and
this is
indicated in the peer-reviewed
literature indicate a difference so if
there's a difference and the quran makes
this clear it says
human being has been created weak allah
describes this and this the mufester on
the exegetes
he they they say this is referring to
sexual weakness this is a weakness
for men
it's much more exacerbated for men
because the once again go into farin's
definition lack of power you know the
fact that we don't have as much
control over sexual desires as women do
should be
something which once again the
complementary system
yes should mean that the woman helps us
a little bit with this because quite
frankly there is an expectation there is
and he's right and he says this in other
places
there is a societal expectation for men
to pro
protect women in other scenarios men if
there was some kind of he was talking
about in another video that i watched of
his
you know the plane uh dropped or
something like that in the sea and women
and children were
kind of told to exit first and the women
and children rule applies over and over
again
women and children are prioritizing
safety matters the truth of the matter
is
if society should operate in those ways
and we don't deny that that should be
the case by the way
we're happy with that well we haven't
got an issue with that really well yeah
but if such weaknesses of women
quite frankly are to be kind of dealt
with by the strengths of men
then at least let the opposite happen
let the weaknesses of man
be hel will help us no no no no no no no
no no help us
it's very simple yeah biologically
emotionally intellectually
you name it whatever you want to name
okay this shows you that this is a peer
review this is this is studies showing
this
yeah if a man has a higher sex drive or
or whatever it is it shows that we need
a unique attention in that area
that's right this person is not me let
me make it clear this doesn't mean
i'm going to force my wife no we're not
talking about we're not talking about
we shouldn't even we shouldn't even we
shouldn't even understand what we're
saying
sadly we have to sadly but we have to
yeah the thing is this
if in a certain situation where there's
a threat to my me and my wife walking
down the road
yes and i have to perform i'm not going
to say go
yeah i have to because because of her
strength it's biological because of my
stress
if that is the case at that given moment
that i have to perform in that very
moment to that threat yeah
it's as good as saying so you're you're
a full-time security guard okay yes but
so that means in a certain area
yeah i'm playing sadly yeah so and i
could die i can die on the course yeah
so the thing is if it comes to intimacy
and if a husband is asking his wife to
come
have intimacy and she's saying no no
problem you have the right to say no
but what you're doing is now you're
hypocrite you're an absolute
walking talking hypocrite yeah that's it
because you're you're happy
you're happy to take protection of men
when weaknesses of women are
uh are shown yeah look i i i totally
agree with this point and i think this
is sadly like you've said something
which is
do you know what this shows among all
above all things yes
the fact that he said this and so many
people have agreed with him on this and
they're not muslims right
yeah so this is not a muslim specific
issue number one okay you can't
attribute this
this behavior to islam this is a
non-muslim website uh
youtube page number one number two okay
which i think is very important as well
is that this shows how much resentment
there is among men for women who do this
to them
now you can see you can feel the
although he's trying to be kind of
monotone
but you can kind of hear through his
content the emotion in his
in in what he's trying to say he's been
probably her
many of the people that are going on his
website youtube page have been hurt and
that is because
let me tell you the reason why is
because the system has been unjust
towards men
and also has been unjust towards women
and this system is
unjust towards men and women the answer
is reciprocity
the answer is complementarity and the
answer is islam
until next time
sorry about this bro